now if you have a thyroid problem
this video is going to be very very
important to you the first thing you
need to know is that
most
thyroid conditions
both hyper
and hypo involved auto immune
thyroid disease in other words ninety
percent of
hypothyroid conditions
are an autoimmune condition called
hashimoto's and seventy percent of the
hyperthyroid conditions
are graves disease which is another
autoimmune disease and so now let's talk
about the relationship between gluten
and the thyroid because
gluten creates celiac which is an
inflammatory condition which destroys a
little villi the little roots of the
intestine which then allow the proteins
to invade the lymphatic system and the
immune system and now you have these
antibodies that attack this protein and
so gluten is a protein it's the protein
of certain grains especially wheat rye
barley and others but gluten in the
digestive system turns into
gliadin and the protein gliadin
looks very very similar if not certain
parts of it identical
to something in your thyroid which is an
enzyme called
transglutaminase so if you have
antibodies that are attacking this
protein in wheat anytime you consume
grains these antibodies are going to not
just attack that protein it's going to
attack the thyroid as well simply
because of this molecular mimicry
situation and there's a lot of other
autoimmune conditions that have a
similar type
principle where you have this mimicry of
either a virus or a food that mimics
a body tissue but in the case of the
thyroid whether you have a hyper or hypo
you definitely need to
remove gluten from the diet 100
because every time you consume it your
body's going to look at that as a
foreign invader and it's going to
actually attack that with its antibodies
as well as certain parts of your thyroid
creating this inflammatory state all
right there are five things that i'm
going to recommend number one
you have to be completely gluten free
number two you want to get on keto the
healthy version of keto and intermittent
fasting why because it's going to lower
your inflammation next thing you want to
take is selenium selenium is essential
for
autoimmune conditions especially with
the thyroid whether you have a hyper or
a hypothyroid condition the big thing
you need to be aware of with a hyper
thyroid condition graves
is that you want to avoid taking iodine
because your thyroid is already
producing too many thyroid hormones and
those thyroid hormones are made from
iodine the other thing you want to avoid
is bile salts because bile salts will
increase the
conversion from the inactive form t4 to
the active form t3 but if you have a
hypo thyroid condition
you definitely want to take purified
bowel salts and that would be oxbile or
any of the bile supplements that are out
there so selenium is good for hyper and
hypo
next thing you want to do is take
vitamin d3
minimally 10 000 ius why because vitamin
d can help you with your inflammation
it's one of the best natural
anti-inflammatory
vitamins out there
and the last thing to take is probiotics
simply because
most autoimmune conditions start in the
gut because you want to start building
up that weak link in your gut alright
thanks for watching
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your
success story
please share it in the link down below